Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je propose que nous commencions
par le petit jeu traditionnel des TEDx,
et je vous propose de lever la main
pour ceux qui ont déjà
entendu parler du métavers.
Oh là, ça fait plus…
Je ne m’y attendais pas.
Maintenant, on va faire différemment.
On va tenter : ceux qui ont
entendu parler du métavers en bien.
Il y a déjà une différence
beaucoup plus marquée.
Ok, le métavers, on en a beaucoup
entendu parler l’année dernière,
moins cette année, ça s’est calmé,
mais l’année dernière,
ça a fait beaucoup de gros titres,
ça a beaucoup été discuté
dans les réseaux sociaux
et pas toujours en bien, voire rarement.
On a eu dans la presse
des gros titres pour nous dire
que tel cabinet de conseil avait évalué
le futur chiffre d’affaires du métavers
à, à peu près, 100 trilliardsde dollars
d’ici 2030,
un autre a dit plus tard
que maintenant, c’était 30 trilliards.
On ne sait pas trop comment
ils font leurs calculs.
On a eu des sociétés qui ont annoncé
en grande pompe
préparer leur propre métavers,
tandis que la société Meta qui avait
déjà mis 11 milliards de dollars
pour son propre métavers,
nous régalait d’affiches dans le métro,
les bus et sur les réseaux sociaux.
On a aussi eu beaucoup de sociétés
qui ont déclaré vouloir vendre
leurs propres produits
dans des centres commerciaux
sur le métavers,
avec des centres commerciaux
parfois très vides
et une qualité graphique
qui laissait parfois à désirer.
Ça, c'était pour les gros titres.
Du côté réseaux sociaux,
ce n’était pas non plus très heureux.
On a eu ceux qui ont annoncé
des futurs dystopiques,
ceux qui nous ont dit que le métavers
consisterait à nous laisser
un casque de réalité virtuelle
sur le crâne 24 h sur 24.
Personnellement, je ne tiens pas plus
de 3 h, ça commence à faire mal au cou.
On a eu ceux qui dénonçaient
un monstre énergivore qui engloutirait
des quantités folles d’énergie.
En fait, tous ces gens-là
ont un point commun.
C’est-à-dire qu’ils ont parlé
de quelque chose qui n’existe même pas.
Aujourd’hui, nous n’avons même pas
quelque chose que l’on puisse
décemment appeler un métavers.
On a évidemment des sociétés
et des applications comme Roblox,
comme Sandbox, comme Fortnite,
comme Horizon World,
qui se rapprochent de l’esprit
d’un métavers et qui peuvent accueillir
jusqu’à plusieurs millions
d’utilisateurs en même temps.
Certes, mais ce qu’on appelle
l’Internet du futur,
ça ne suppose pas quelques millions,
pas quelques dizaines,
ni quelques centaines.
ça suppose pratiquement un milliard
de personnes connectées en même temps.
Et ça, on ne sait pas faire.
On ne sait pas faire au niveau logiciel,
on ne sait pas faire au niveau
infrastructure matérielle.
En fait, on est tellement au début
du cycle de création du métavers
que nous n’avons même pas
encore de définition
qui fasse consensus
parmi les professionnels.
Que sera vraiment le métavers ?
On va essayer de se faire une petite
définition très simple entre nous.
Le métavers, il faudrait le voir
comme une espèce d’œuf
qui contiendrait une infinité
de mondes virtuels tous différents
des mondes virtuels
pour apprendre, pour travailler,
pour essayer des choses en toute sécurité,
contrairement à ce qu’on pourrait faire
dans la réalité,
des mondes virtuels
pour communiquer, être sociaux,
des mondes virtuels aussi
pour avoir des blogs
qui ne seraient plus simplement
des pages 2D
mais des planètes entières
qu’on pourrait concevoir
en fonction de nos goûts et nos envies.
Pourquoi pas ?
Et donc, chacun de ces mondes
a deux spécificités
qui sont à la base de tout.
La première spécificité,
c’est qu’ils seraient tous interopérables.
C’est-à-dire que vous,
en tant que personne
représentée par votre avatar,
vous pourriez facilement passer
d’un monde à un autre,
puis encore un autre,
sans avoir à chaque fois
à sortir de l’application,
rentrer à nouveau vos identifiants
dans une autre application, etc.
La deuxième chose, c’est qu’il faudrait
que ces mondes-là puissent…
Trou de mémoire…
(Applaudissements)
L’interopérabilité et la persistance.
Voilà, j’y suis ! Donc, il faut
que ce soient des mondes persistants :
même lorsque vous n’y êtes pas,
que vous coupez votre machine,
ces mondes vont continuer
à évoluer sans vous,
à être visités par d’autres personnes.
Ça, c’est vraiment le noyau de l’affaire
pour ce qui est du futur métavers
en plus du nombre de personnes
connectées en même temps.
Donc aujourd’hui, on ne sait pas faire,
ni au niveau logiciel,
ni en termes d’infrastructures,
rien de tout ça.
Donc on ne peut pas avoir de métavers.
Alors pourquoi venir
vous en parler ce soir ?
Il y a déjà eu plein de TED talks
qui ont parlé du sujet.
Certains très bien.
Ce qui m’intéresserait,
c’est de vous parler de ça
sous deux angles différents :
le premier, c’est les cas d’usage
parce qu’on a beaucoup parlé de chiffre
d’affaires et de produits à vendre.
Mais, les cas d’usage,
on en a rarement entendu parler.
Avec mon expérience professionnelle,
je voudrais vous présenter
trois cas d’usage
que je trouve pertinents
pour justifier l’intérêt du métavers.
Le premier cas d’usage,
ce serait celui-ci :
vous voyez une église
qui se trouvait à la frontière
de l’Allemagne et de la France,
bombardée pendant
la Seconde guerre mondiale
et complètement détruite.
J’ai accompagné l’équipe d’archéologues
qui faisaient les fouilles des fondations
et j’ai pu reconstituer
le reste de l’église.
Mais pour nous aider,
nous n’avions à l’époque
que deux petites photos en noir et blanc,
vraiment très ennuyeuses,
avec très peu de détails.
Heureusement, on a eu la chance
de rencontrer une grand-mère
qui avait 92 ans à l’époque et qui avait
très bien connu cette église
parce qu’elle s’y était mariée.
On lui a montré la maquette en cours
de réalisation, et encore, très grossière,
sa mémoire, contre toute attente,
s’est totalement débloquée
et pendant trois heures,
elle nous a régalé d’anecdotes,
de points de détails
et de petites histoires
qui nous ont permis de reconstituer
complètement cette église
bien au-delà de nos espérances.
Au moment de partir, elle a posé
ses mains sur mes épaules et m’a dit :
« Merci monsieur. Grâce à vous,
j’ai retrouvé ma jeunesse. »
Et ça, pour moi, ça a été un déclic.
Parce que jusqu’à présent,
j’abordais mon métier sous un angle
de médiateur scientifique.
On transformait une quantité
d’informations en une chose
simple à comprendre pour les gens.
Et là, je découvrais qu’en fait mon
travail avait un impact sur les personnes,
sur la mémoire.
Et pourquoi pas permettre aux gens
de retrouver, par la visite à nouveau
de lieux connus mais qui n’existent plus,
des souvenirs qu’ils pensaient enfouis.
Ça ne vaudrait-il pas le coup,
par le métavers, de permettre aux gens
de retrouver leurs souvenirs ainsi ?
Je pense que si.
Le deuxième cas d’usage, c’est le temple
que vous voyez sur l’image.
Aujourd’hui, si vous voulez le visiter,
vous allez prendre votre voiture, conduire
un certain temps, arriver sur place
et au moment où vous pensez
découvrir ce très joli temple romain,
vous ne voyez rien du tout,
il n’existe plus.
Il n’y a plus qu’une motte de terre
qui recouvre les quelques restes
archéologiques de la base.
Plutôt décevant.
En France et partout dans le monde,
nous avons des milliers
de sites historiques
avec un très fort potentiel patrimonial,
mais qui soit n’existent plus aujourd’hui
car détruits comme le temple,
soit trop abîmés pour être visités.
C’est quand même dommage
que ces sites qui n’ont pas toujours
la possibilité d’avoir
une médiation humaine sur place,
ne puissent plus être exploités ni offrir
leur potentiel d’histoire au grand public.
Là encore, ne pourrait-on pas utiliser
le métavers pour ça ?
Je pense que si.
Le troisième cas d’usage,
c’est celui que j’ai pu
expérimenter en 2016,
Là, c’est une recréation
de la véritable scène,
parce que je n’avais pas pu
prendre une photo,
mais j’ai voulu me poser la question :
serait-il pertinent d’utiliser
la réalité virtuelle dans les EHPAD,
auprès des personnes plus en mesure
d’utiliser leur corps normalement ?
Lors des tests que j’ai faits
avec le personnel soignant,
on m’a notamment présenté un monsieur
sur son lit-chariot
qu’il ne quittait jamais,
ce monsieur avait son corps pratiquement
paralysé, ses mains étaient figées.
J’ai mis le casque
de réalité virtuelle sur sa tête
et il s’est retrouvé en train
de flotter du côté de la Lune.
Grosse surprise, et quand il a compris
qu’il pouvait regarder absolument partout,
il s’est enthousiasmé et au lieu d’appuyer
lui-même sur la manette pour passer
de la Lune à Mars
et Jupiter à Uranus, etc.,
c’est moi qui le faisais
lorsqu’il me disait « Suivant ».
Et voilà notre papi qui décolle vers Mars
et qui me dit : « Waouh ! Suivant ! »
Je l’envoie un peu plus loin,
« Suivant ! Suivant ! »
encore plus loin, il sort du système
solaire, « Suivant ! Suivant ! »
Bref, il était complément parti,
on ne le retrouve plus.
Lui ne pouvait pas nous voir,
avec son casque sur le visage,
mais le personnel soignant
et moi, on se souriait,
sachant que quelque chose
de magique se passait,
que ce monsieur était vraiment en train
de transcender sa condition actuelle
pour faire ce qu’il n’aurait jamais
imaginé pouvoir faire.
Certes, c’était du virtuel,
mais quand le réel ne peut plus,
c’est là où le virtuel
prend tout son sens.
Donc voilà, pensez à des personnes
que vous connaissez.
Ne serait-il pas sympa pour elles
d’aller faire de la plongée
dans les abysses des océans ?
Ne serait-il pas sympa pour elles
d’aller escalader l’Everest
surfer sur les dunes du Sahara
plutôt que de rester coincées chez elles ?
Personnellement, je pense que si.
Le problème, c’est que de métavers,
on risque de ne jamais avoir, en fait.
Parce que tout comme l’écran ici
affiche des images,
l’image virtuelle a besoin
de support réel pour pouvoir exister.
Quand on parle de réalité virtuelle,
on parle souvent
d’appareil réel numérique.
Ce qu’on ne sait pas,
c’est que ces appareils,
casques de réalité virtuelle
ou smartphones
que nous avons tous en poche,
ont des impacts bien réels
et particulièrement graves
pour notre environnement.
Donc si on doit parler de ces impacts,
on essaie de découper
en cycle de vie d’un appareil,
avec un début, un milieu, une fin.
Le milieu, vous le connaissez tous.
Chaque fois qu'on allume l'appareil,
on utilise de l'énergie électrique.
L’électricité en France,
on ne s’en sort pas trop mal,
mais dans le monde, elle est produite
à 80% par des sources carbonées,
des ressources fossiles.
Ça veut dire que,
pour un térawatt-heure produit,
on a consommé soit du gaz,
soit du charbon, soit du pétrole,
et que ces ressources, tôt ou tard,
il n’y en aura plus.
Parlons d’abord du début des appareils,
quand ils doivent être construits.
Un appareil numérique,
qu’est-ce que ça suppose ?
Ça suppose du pétrole, encore,
pour pouvoir faire les pièces plastiques
et les matières composites, du verre,
mais aussi des minerais
pour pouvoir créer les métaux.
Un appareil comme le smartphone
dans ma poche,
c’est entre 34 et 50 métaux différents,
de l’or, de l’aluminium, de l’argent,
du zinc, du gallium,
du tantale, du cobalt,
plein, plein, plein
de minerais différents.
Ces minerais, comment on les récupère ?
On va commencer déjà par décaper
une très vaste surface,
plusieurs kilomètres carrés
et puis on va commencer à creuser.
On va creuser de plus en plus.
Comme vous le voyez sur l’image,
une fois que la couche viable,
toute la couche où se trouve
la biodiversité a été supprimée,
on va attaquer l’écorce terrestre
pour pouvoir enlever de plus en plus
de minerais agglomérés,
plein de minerais différents,
dans de grands blocs
que nous allons prélever.
Les machines que vous voyez sur l’image
sont des excavatrices à godets.
Chaque machine a l’air petite
parce que le site est gigantesque.
Mais en fait, ces machines-là
font 240 mètres de long,
pèsent 13 500 tonnes et vont prélever,
avec leurs godets rotatifs,
chaque jour, plusieurs centaines
de tonnes d’écorce terrestre,
dans laquelle se trouvent
les fameux minerais.
Donc vous voyez, ça a quand même
été bien décapé, là.
Et toute la biodiversité qui a été enlevée
ne reviendra jamais de notre vivant.
Une fois qu’on a ces minerais,
on va pouvoir commencer à construire.
Le problème est de trouver
les sources des minerais en question.
Si on prend le cobalt qui a, lui aussi,
pas mal défrayé la chronique récemment.
Le cobalt se trouve aux deux tiers,
pour les ressources mondiales, au Congo.
Et on en trouve une proportion de 4%
de cobalt dans les minerais qu’on prélève.
En Europe du Nord, on tombe
jusqu’à 0,4% de cobalt.
Et le reste du monde
n’a qu’un tiers des ressources de cobalt.
Donc ça va poser un certain problème
d’approvisionnement.
L’autre souci, c’est la manière
dont est extrait le cobalt en question.
Parce que contrairement aux pays riches
qui eux, ont des excavatrices,
au Congo, ils n’ont pas ça.
Ils ont des pelles, des pioches
et des enfants.
Et ils sont obligés d’y aller à la main
pour récupérer les fameux blocs de roche
dans lesquels se trouvent
les différents minerais.
On a parlé du milieu de vie et du début,
on va parler de la fin.
Notre super smartphone, le compagnon
qu’on a depuis cinq ans dans la poche,
on se ramasse une pub venant
d’un Black Friday quelconque
ou notre opérateur nous propose
de renouveler notre forfait
avec en prime un nouveau smartphone,
pourquoi pas ?
Donc, celui-là, on va finir
par s’en débarrasser.
Une certaine partie d’entre eux
iront dans nos tiroirs.
On estime qu’à peu près 4 milliards
d’appareils vont se retrouver
dans nos placards à croupir un moment
avant qu’on décide
de s’en débarrasser pour de bon.
Pour le reste, vous vous dites :
« Je vais l’emmener à la déchetterie,
il va être recyclé, c’est cool. »
Dans la pratique, ça ne va pas
du tout se passer comme ça.
En pratique, si on voulait reconstruire
un smartphone neuf
à partir de ceux qui ont été mis
en déchetterie, il en faudrait un millier.
Mille appareils pour un smartphone.
Dans la pratique, c’est uniquement
17% de nos appareils numériques
placés en déchetterie qui seront recyclés.
Donc on se retrouve avec un problème
d’appareils impossibles à recycler.
On pourrait le faire,
mais ça coûte tellement cher
que personne ne le fera réellement.
L’autre souci,
c’est que pendant ce temps-là,
la quantité de nos déchets
électroniques ne cesse d’augmenter.
On finit par avoir des décharges
qui sont saturées.
Ces mêmes appareils,
au lieu d’être recyclés, finissent
par croupir à l’air libre ou être enfouis.
Dans les pires des cas,
on les met dans des gros bateaux
et on les envoie
vers les pays les plus pauvres,
Asie du Sud ou ici comme au Ghana.
Ce que vous voyez sur l’image,
c’était la plus grande décharge
de déchets électroniques du monde.
Les gens qui travaillaient là
pour recycler
les quelques particules de métal
qu’ils pouvaient bien recycler
ne le pouvaient
qu’au système D, à la main,
ou avec des moyens de fortune.
Ce faisant, leurs sols
et leurs cours d’eau
étaient tellement pollués
que leur espérance de vie
était généralement diminuée de 30 ans.
Le tout pour un salaire de misère.
Va-t-on pouvoir continuer
longtemps comme ça ?
Je ne sais pas.
On a un cycle de vie qui,
à tous les égards,
pour l’usage du numérique,
a des impacts qui sont vraiment
importants et néfastes.
Et là, vous allez me dire :
« Il nous fait deux TED talks
en même temps ?
D’un côté, il nous vend le métavers
comme un truc génial
et de l’autre il nous dit que le numérique
est en train de détruire la planète. »
En fait, c’est vraiment
comme cette médaille-là.
C’est-à-dire que vous avez le côté pile,
le métavers et tous les services
numériques équivalents, et les impacts
qui sont forcément avec.
Donc si je devais ce soir vous laisser
repartir avec un message,
ce serait celui-ci.
Un autre numérique est possible.
Posez-vous un peu les questions.
Chez vous, avez-vous besoin
d’avoir jusqu’à quinze appareils
connectés en même temps,
dont des porte-manteaux, des frigos
et des pots de fleurs ?
Et ce ne sont pas les pires.
Quand vous utilisez votre smartphone,
vous avez vraiment besoin
de regarder des vidéos de chatons
à la volée pendant des heures ?
Pareil, lorsque vous avez envie
de vous faire un bon film sur Netflix,
faut-il absolument le regarder
en ultra HD, voire en 4K, 6K, 8K ?
Quand vous décidez de changer
de smartphone parce que,
à un moment ou un autre,
ils finissent par devenir trop vieux,
a-t-on besoin d’obéir forcément
à la proposition
des opérateurs téléphoniques
ou aux dernières injonctions
du Black Friday ?
Pourquoi pas profiter d’appareils
reconditionnés ou de ce qu’on appelle
des Fairphone, qui sont
entièrement démontables ?
Enfin, a-t-on vraiment besoin
d’avoir autant de mises à jour logicielles
qui finissent par rendre
obsolètes bien avant l’heure
nos appareils électroniques ?
Pour conclure, je vous dirai ceci.
Le métavers peut vraiment être
une chose géniale
et dont les impacts pourraient
largement surpasser en bien
les impacts négatifs qu’entraînerait
forcément son usage.
Donc, je vous le demande,
donnons-lui simplement une chance
de pouvoir nous le prouver.
Merci pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)